[Music]
scientists around the world are racing
to record the genetic blueprints of all
the earth's known species before some of
them could disappear forever the
researchers plan to spend a decade
digitizing the dna of animals and plants
to learn how to protect them
and our planet in the future it is
called the earth
biogenome project and as roxanna saberi
reports researchers in england are
taking their mission
very seriously
i don't know if i really want to do this
but i'm going to ask hazel
can i hold
a ball
you can have a go at holding a bowl okay
they do have very sharp teeth and quite
a strong bite but it is essentially a
rodent right that i'm holding right now
it is yeah it's a rodent it's a bit
cuter than a rat yeah they're much cuter
water bowls may be rodents but
conservationist hazel ryan says they're
one of the uk's most endangered animals
millions of water bowls used to live
along the uk's waterways
but with their numbers plunging by
around 95 percent in recent decades
they're now protected and bred in
sanctuaries like this why do voles
matter bowls
are very important part of the ecosystem
because they feed on plants they dig
burrows
and they're also food for other animals
so they're part of the food chain and
whenever one creature is threatened she
says so is the balance of life on our
planet
if you affect one one species they can
have knock-on effects on other species
which rely on it
that's exactly what's happening around
the world the un says around 1 million
plant and animal species like the black
rhino and the mountain gorilla are at
risk of extinction more than at any
other time in human history
and that climate change plastic
pollution deforestation and our
exploding global population are to blame
that's why scientists worldwide are
racing to sequence the genetic codes of
the earth's one and a half million known
species from the water bowl and the rare
gooty tarantula to the common cricket
even the oak tree don't only want to
sequence the oak tree yes we don't
sequence all the other things that live
on oak trees neuroscientist mark baxter
is helping lead the uk's program called
the tree of life everything's
interconnected everything's
interconnected so 400 species living on
this one oak tree he hopes that by
documenting the dna of this diversity we
can learn how various species evolved
and could keep evolving how they're
responding to human activities
and how to protect them and us
we need the services that these plants
and animals and fungi
give us
services like oxygen food and medicine
and so by understanding how they do it
we can help humans as well
how concerned are you that some of these
species
after you sequence them will disappear
quite
off the southwest coast of england the
race is on too
researchers have already collected
hundreds of samples of species from
seaweed to snails to starfish but it
will take them years to collect tens of
thousands more
joanna harley helps trawl for treasures
at least once a week this is absolutely
urgent why is it so urgent i think it's
really important to protect species on
this planet they share it with us and
they keep it going
and the more we erode away at
the world the less there will be
and what did you find
oh gosh
oh this is the other half some finds are
so unfamiliar they require good
old-fashioned research
back on land the team sorts through the
specimens then ships them to sequencing
labs like this one at the welcome sanger
institute near cambridge
so far british researchers have recorded
the genetic blueprints of nearly 400 of
the country's roughly 70 000 known
species
all the data is shared online in the
spirit of open science
in 50 years what difference do you think
your work will make so we'll be able to
look at a species and work out whether
it's endangered or not and will know
what to do
to keep it going you're hopeful oh yeah
these scientists say decoding dna won't
alone save endangered plants and animals
but it can help us learn to respect and
protect all the wonders of the world big
and small for cbs saturday morning
roxanna saberi kent england
knowledge is good
all i could think of during that piece
is the circle of life from the lion king
and hearing that song playing but it is
we're all interconnected it really is a
race against time especially when you
hear that a million species animal and
plant species are at the risk of
extinction more than any time in history
and it was amazing 400 species just on
that one oak tree i know i know uh and
then the species they found on the water
that they didn't even know what it was
right right so about it a little
differently amazing